okay I'm video running let's try to get
some opponent here in the five minutes
started okay first game cancer
Grandmaster on your shake from the
United States no idea who that is but
let's see got a king's indian he goes
for Bishop b3 k match one yeah this is
an interesting line like knight c6
mmm the possible to play Knight d4 you
94 is possible and some sometimes take
sidi-ji phone takes on c3 okay let's try
this you can of course also go for
something something like this when I
hope I'll get enough- play now f5 maybe
what you for saying so I need to do
something about that I think I think
this is theoretical line I can take on a
phone or thing should be four then
between h4 with f2 threatening mate
ok this is forced yeah but I'm I like
black here actually I should just get
the piece back with a bishop Pam and
also it's getting open here so the
bishops are actually have got some
possibilities k interesting now both
captures are possible take the bishop
came
I cannot cancel long and counseling
short she seems risky also i'm only
asking myself if bitten I'd be five
might be an idea yeah I'd like to
prevent that okay to drop this back
pusher g5 I think I should have queen
age five because on g4 i can simply take
ok he cancels long Bishop g5 now I can I
can capture f2 but let's open up some
lines here also need to keep an eye on
the clock a little bit behind as always
but it's not not dramatic yet
not sure what you should play now and
yeah this make sense to get some some
play in the center okay but is it
dangerous ok I think I I need to take it
it takes e4 now does he have something
really threatening don't think some you
can go on 25 of course threaten e7 not
sure if this is some really really
dangerous okay I could certainly just go
to h eight
u7 I have recovered ok interesting move
of course I cannot take on on d4 not
sure that really accomplishes anything
it's just go back here he cannot take
with the rook now anywhere and I
threatened just Ruby aid and capture
e-cigs maybe also see five at some point
p2 is hanging c5 rope t2c three ok
what if I play I just let's just get
this back and keep it simple should be a
good position anyway
so now c5 first I think let him drop
back and cover the porn now this one
first first threat not be too let's see
how he intends to cover this
don't see a really good time morning yes
the only move her so as well d 5 maybe
t5 could be strong okay keep it simple
okay not sure what he's doing I'm just
pile up on be too must be good okay I
could I could actually win the Queen now
yeah the chance go for this check that's
just an extra queen everything's well
coordinated I think okay let's get the
points rolling now check
check check check check check
quite resigned yeah looked like pretty
pretty clean win just have a quick recap
here I'm not sure why we really ran
wrong but this already looks like a
comfortable position I don't like
canceling long much here because I get
so so easy play with b5 well it's hard
to tell without really am deeper
analysis what what went wrong here yeah
this is very nice for black okay let's
have a quick look if it's a grandmaster
it doesn't have the name in it okay well
on to the next game